So I woke up this morning and reviewed some of
my preferred sources for the sort of like what
happened yesterday in right wing media and
came across something that made me wonder,
did we perfect time travel?
Have we traveled back
to the time when Barack Obama was president?
Because on Fox News, propagandist Sean Hannity
wasted. No, he's not even waiting for Joe Biden
to be sworn in. He wasted no time. He is already
warning about concentration camps that the left
is going to set up for Trump supporters. They did
this under Barack Obama. Conspiracy theorists and
others talking about a forced internment camps.
Some of them use the term FEMA camps. Some of
them actually use the term concentration camps.
And now this is remember, in a year when this
is this has exploded, that today I am playing
for you what I believe is the start of the Biden
will put Trump ists in concentration camps. Meme,
this is the twenty, twenty one version of it.
And they never change their conspiracy theories.
They just change who it is that's going to do it
to you. Sean Hannity saying they want to put Trump
in reeducation camps. Take a look at this.
Education camps deprogramming. OK,
according to the press wing of the Democratic
Establishment Party and the Socialist Party,
you, we, the people, we need to be deprogrammed
or canceled or put in reeducation camps
because of our political opinion. And it
differs from theirs. Sadly, after decades
on TV and radio. Let me just tell you what this is
really all about now, this effort from the left,
it is not new. It's only accelerating. I'm not
complaining, but this has really been my reality.
Now, Sean Hannity is correct. They do
need to be deprogrammed or reprogramed,
but a no serious leftist thinks putting people
in camps is the way to deprogram Trump. I also
like how he says this is the dictate from the
Socialist Party. What's what Socialist Party.
There's no one in power in the United
States from the Socialist Party.
AOC claims to be a democratic socialist and is
really more of a social Democrat. What where
where are these powerful socialists hidden that
they even have influence in the United States?
That's another red flag that maybe Sean
Hannity isn't actually telling you the truth.
And I hate to tell you, it pains me to tell you
this because it feels like we're just rewinding
back to 2015, 2016. This stuff is going to
go on for as long as Joe Biden is president.
The differences you I argue that the difference
about, for example, concentration, internment,
reeducation camps, conspiracy's in twenty twenty
one versus twenty fourteen is that in 2014 way
fewer people fell for them. But the number
of people that have fallen for this. Q And on
Wild Trump is stuff tells us that there is a much
larger group of Americans susceptible to it today
than there was during President Barack
Obama's presidency. And that's really scary.
That's something that we I don't know how we
deal with that because we've got Newsmax and on
signal boosting it. And the you know, you did you
occasionally had internment camps from FEMA camps
mentioned on Fox News during Obama's presidency.
But this is going to be the bread and butter of
Newsmax of 08 and of others. Now, if Sean Hannity
by reeducation camp simply means we need to fix
schools so that people come out of school better
able to think for themselves, not susceptible to
the propaganda of Fox News and of OCN and
of Newsmax, then listen, guilty as charged.
I want to improve education, that's for sure.
I want to be teaching critical thinking. I want
to be teaching epistemology guilty as charged.
If what the allegation is, is that we want to
better educate people, but consider the irony
that they are the ones who have been shouting,
lock them up, lock her up, lock him
up at rallies for five years now.
But the day before Joe Biden is sworn in, they go
back to they're going to put Trump in camps. Come
on, guys. Consider the irony that they are
the ones that came up with and perpetuated
the war on drugs, incarcerating so many people for
minor drug infractions. But they say it's the left
that wants to lock people up in camps. What this
doesn't even pass the sniff test. But as usual,
with these people, it's all projection. Now, one
last thought when we talk about radicalization.
And what gets people to go out and try to do real
world violence, this is a perfect example, beating
people over the head for months or years when they
want to put you in camps, they want to put you
in camps because of your political beliefs. This
is what gets some people in their audience, some
to decide, I'm going to go out and I'm going
to do something horrible. OK, one very last
thing I thought I was on the last thing, but
I have one more thing. You can only call it a
reeducation camp. If there's been education done
before for a lot of these people, they're just
lacking the education to begin with around a lot
of these issues, including how government works,
how to think critically, how to understand
and interpret media messages for yourself. So
for many folks, the education problem is
so bad that there's no reeducation to do.
There's been no education. You say to people,
how do you determine whether a message you see
on the news is true or false? That I don't know.
I've never thought about it. I've never devoted
nobody's ever given me a framework for how to
think about that. So this is a signal that much as
we've been predicting for months, it's all going
back to the standard Republican playbook, right
wing media projecting onto the left the things
that actually would be better applied to them,
pretending to care about the budget and pretending
to care about small government and getting
government out, obstruction of religious freedom.
First Amendment explosion's. They're going back to
the playbook. So buckle up for some crazy times.
I was going to say we'll be covering it once Joe
Biden is sworn in, but we're covering it now
because they're wasting no time getting started